[Music]
do you want to team up with your friends
and put an end to some cocaine Cowboys
well the Ghost Recon wildlands open beta
will give you that opportunity when it
kicks off next week I'm Matt this is a
game spot news update and make sure to
hit those like and subscribe buttons for
more open world firefights and
explosions the Ghost Recon wildlands
open beta runs from februari 23rd
through the 27th on ps4 xbox one and pc
the open beta includes everything from
the closed beta in addition to a new
province called monti rock which
features heavily defended struggled
where you can expect to find some of the
drug cartels soldiers freeloading begins
on februari 21st and anyone who took
part in the closed beta or tries the
open one will get three exclusive
missions when the game releases in March
Ghost Recon wildlands launches for ps4
xbox one and pc on march seven it
contains the largest open world that
Ubisoft has ever made but we're still
not sure that size makes it a better
game you can expect gamespot's review
closer to the release date so while you
wait check out our video on the things
that could use improvement from the
closed beta